well throughout this crisis we've been
keeping a close eye on the impact of
covert 19 on the UK in terms of the
numbers the data and this chart in
particular it is a very depressing chart
showing you the death tolls in various
countries around the world but
depressing as it is it's also very
important because how steep these lines
reflects how fast the disease is
spreading in these countries so when
people talk about flattening the curve
this is what they mean getting these
lines which are steep here this shows
growth rates to flatten out over the
course of the next few weeks you look at
the difference we North Korea in many
countries in Europe for a sense of what
we're talking about here and if you
compare in particular Italy with the UK
so there's Italy showing a very steep
increase and this is a logarithmic chart
like I said it's a growth rate shot
let's add the UK on there and see how it
compares for most of the last few weeks
the UK has been below Italy but we just
had the announcement that there have
been six thousand 159 total deaths in
the UK a depressing number the highest
daily death toll as well that we've had
yet but as sir patrick valence was
saying earlier on there is some cause
for hope because look back about a week
ago that line was steeper it was
doubling every three days the rate at
the total death toll but in the past
week it's got a bit flatter so now
doubling every four days so a flatter
line is better news for the UK
nonetheless if you extrapolate that on
another week or so you're still talking
about the UK overtaking Italy in terms
of the severity of the crisis getting to
10,000 deaths by the weekend that's a
terrible number but it's worth just
bearing in mind a lot of people thought
that might happen even earlier if that
line have been steeper so some evidence
that a lockdown is starting to work
there but you have to bear in mind there
are all sorts of different ways of
measuring these statistics so in even
when it comes to death rates so those
numbers come from the government each
day we get a daily atoll of how many
people have died but there was a big
difference between that announcement
that's the lower line there and what's
actually happening on those given days
which we only find out later on and that
gap actually might account for about 22%
or so so we might be under counting
deaths each day by about 22% at least in
the increase of this crisis but we all
starting to get a sense now that this
has real implications for the UK as a
whole and indeed for death rates as a
whole this shows you weekly deaths from
all causes so not just Co vat19 you can
see Co vat19 there 539 deaths in the
week to the 27th of March but then there
are all other causes as well and what's
significant about this is this area now
of total deaths has overtaken the
average that dotted line so we are in a
situation now where people talk about
excess deaths excess mortalities in the
UK that is real concern but there are
some signs for hope as I say with those
overall death rates and the lines might
be flattening now